people like all of us you put toothpaste
on your pimple you sleep with a potato
slice over your pimple and hope that
when you wake up it disappears things
like that face oil my rose quartz roller
and some lip gloss growing up my
relationship with my hair was a
beautiful one I learned at a young age
to embrace my hair and love my hair my
family and my sisters really try to
instill that in me because I've had my
locks since I was like five years old
and you know growing up around school I
was the only one in my class with locks
so a lot of my classmates would be like
oh what's that hairdo and would try to
pick on me but I would go home to my
sisters and they'd be like no you're
beautiful be confident in your hair